Film Courage: What elements
make up a great story?
Pat Verducci, Writing Coach, Teacher and
Mentor:Well I think when you’re writing
and you sort of have an idea and you goWow, will
this actually make a great feature film or not?I
usually think aboutOkay, are these three elements
part of the idea or could I find a way to sort of
embed these three elements?One is that it needs
to have a main character who wants something
really badly. The second one is it has to promise
lots of conflict. When we imagine the story and we
imagine what the character wants and what they’re
going to have to do to get it, we already start to
kind of imagine all the crazy obstacles that that
person’s going to have to face in order to get
what they want and then we get really interested
right? Then third I think a way to tell if your
idea will make a great movie is does it have
human emotions in it that we can relate to even
if you're writing about science fiction or you're
writing a horror movie or something set way in the
past where you really have no immediate connection
to the time or place or characters there have to
be those human feelings and desires and fears
that we can relate to so I always think those
are the three criteria that make a great movie or
tv idea and obviously if you're writing a tv show
the idea has to promise lots of story when you're
writing a feature it's a contained three-act
structure right so it has it's it's a contained
story with an end so thinking about that idea
all those elements still have to be at play
and then in addition when you're writing a tv
limited series or a tv show with multiple seasons
how are all those characters and all those
conflicts going to spool out and promise lots of
conflict to come yeah great great three tips first
off how would we know that the characters want
is really strong enough that it warrants us being
invested in them right well as a story consultant
I mean I work with a lot of screenwriters I work
with professional screenwriters who are working in
the industry and I also work with beginning people
and people who are kind of in the middle of their
journey toward being a professional screenwriter
but even with the professional screenwriters that
I work with it's always the same it's like every
time I read the script it's like what do they want
and the writer looks at me like I have no idea
like they've written a whole script and they're
just they still kind of don't understand
what the main character wants and so when someone
is thinking about their their main character
I always like to break down what they want
into two parts like they have an emotional
need like to find love or connection or for
revenge or power or whatever and then there's
a specific immediate goal that they pursue in
the story that satisfies that emotional need
so if you don't have those two things and know
them pretty clearly you're probably going to write
a lot of pages that you don't end up having
in your final version of the script because
I don't I don't know about you but I've written
full scripts where I literally have no idea what
they want and this happens this happens this
happens and then I look at the script and I'm
like what is this like what is this thing why
should I be invested in watching this story
so I think a way to know if you if your
character has enough of an engine to drive
a feature or a television show it's like they
have to have a very specific emotional need
and then they have a very specific goal that
they're pursuing in the story to satisfy that need
now when they start the movie or the tv show that
immediate goal that they're pursuing could be like
the wrong thing right and their goal changes
but usually the emotional need stays constant
as they sort of grow then they may change
that that immediate goal to kind of reveal
their their growth as a character or whatever but
like do what your character emotionally needs and
wants and then what is it that they specifically
decide to do to satisfy that need and once you
have that lined up then you're good you're good to
go and start writing with conflict how do we know
how much house like is it too much too soon or
there can never be too much conflict too soon like
some people think they have conflict in their
story and it's actually not it's it's too it's
too meek it's not it's not enough right
that's a great question about conflict
for me like even if you're writing the
most small specific character-driven
movie that takes place in a very kind of
small location with just a few characters
there has to be lots of conflict there needs to
be internal conflict and external conflict of some
kind however that doesn't mean your your movie
has to start with like conflict conflict conflict
conflict too much conflict because after a while
it's like whoa what is this what's happening here
what's this about so one way to sort of think
about conflict and how it works especially
when you're when you're writing a feature film is
that at the beginning of the story your character
may want something that they don't have right and
they're just kind of living their life but we get
the sense that they want something that they don't
have and then there is this inciting incident or
call to adventure where maybe they have the chance
to get what they want but it's like super scary
right like there's something emotionally dangerous
about that call or physically dangerous and so
they go nope I'm going to refuse that call because
I'm too afraid and then something usually happens
to kind of force the person to take action
and heed the call to adventure and go on the
journey at the end of act one so it's not like
you have to have conflict conflict it's like
like usually most really great stories depending
on what genre you're writing in I mean if you're
writing an action movie there should be something
big up top right and then it creates a question
we're like what happened and then we slow down
and we start to go meet up with the character
and what they're trying to figure out so you
can have sections of your script that are quiet
where we're just kind of revealing character and
they're still trying to get what they want but
the conflicts are smaller and more internal but in
the climax of your movie whether you're writing a
tiny movie or you're writing a huge movie where
there's car chases and explosions or whatever
that is the moment where there has
to be big conflict either emotionally
or physically so conflict is something that you
have to kind of modulate throughout the script
right and there are moments in the story that are
quieter where maybe we get in act two we have a
moment where everything kind of slows down and we
have a scene with two characters connecting on a
deeper emotional level that then create bigger
stakes so that when they move into the next
section of conflict the stakes are even higher
just because we had this really tiny quiet little
scene that had no conflict in it so each scene has
to move the story forward and conflict will kind
of ebb and flow but there always has to be tension
in the story and the reason for that is that
every every movie every tv show every
story creates a dramatic question
and the dramatic question is will the person
get what they want or not and that's what
holds us to the story and so if somebody has
a goal and they go after it and they get it
we're like okay the story's over
like but if they want something
and it's really hard either emotionally
or physically we're gonna keep watching
because if we are if we have empathy toward that
character and we understand what they want and why
we generally want them to get it and so we're with
them and that question of will they get it or will
they not get it is what holds us to the story and
in order for us for that question to kind of be
dramatic and suspenseful we need conflict yeah
and so what if the character gets what they want
early in the film but it turns out that
didn't really fulfill their desired need
and we as the viewer go on this journey to see
them get it and we want to root for them and
think oh wow they have it but then it turns out to
be either a disappointment or traumatic to their
lives and so then we follow the rest of the film
of them trying to sort out this this goal right so
so yeah like that that happens a lot in
storytelling right where the character
remember when I was talking about that idea
that they that they have this emotional need
and then they have the specific goal and they
pursue the wrong goal like for example let's just
take a rom a teen rom-com just because that's an
easy genre to talk about so so a trope in rom-coms
especially in the teen sort of world is that
that let's say we have a female character and
she loves the wrong boy she loves Kevin Kevin
is the popular boy Kevin has the swoopy hair
Kevin has the letterman's jacket right and she
wants Kevin so bad and we the audience are going
actually it's joe the nerdy guy that's for you
but but she has to figure it out herself so let's
say she gets together with Kevin and and she's
with Kevin and she's starting to realize like oh
this isn't really good like I don't really like
like him or I don't really like being part of
this this this crowd or whatever she's starting
to realize who she really loves which is joe
but like she rejected joe way back there so now
joe is with sally and now she has to try to get
joe back like it becomes it because it can
become part of you creating an arc for your
main character and they sort of get a deeper
understanding of what it is they really want
that's related to their emotional need for love
and connection I don't know if that answered your
question yeah it does it does and I'm sorry
the third part was are there enough emotions
do we feel empathetic toward the character yeah
okay so so do we so creating empathy I mean for
those of your your viewers who are writing we all
know that the one thing we really need to create
between the audience and the main character is
empathy and empathy to me empathy is sharing the
feelings and understanding why someone's doing
something and recognizing those motives as human
in yourself so even if you have an antagonist
who's like doing despicable disgusting horrible
things if we know why that person is doing it
they feel like a real person right and they're
humanized and they don't feel stereotypical
or villainy like twirling their mustaches
and with a main character empathy is is really
important too because again if we're sharing
the emotions of our main character main character
in the story they're actually the window through
which we're experiencing the journey so the
the function of the hero in storytelling
is for the reader or the audience to actually
be in that person situation and experience that
journey through their eyes and so in order to
do that we have to feel a connection to that
person so a lot of times students or writers
ask me like I want to write an anti-hero like
my my main character is not likeable I don't care
they're not gonna be likable and I'm like great
they don't have to be likable but they do have to
be empathetic in other words we have to understand
their motives why they're doing what they're
doing and so most main characters are likeable
like we we like them and we want them to get
what they want but there are some main characters
like in the talented Mr. Ripley I don't know if
you've seen that movie but Tom Ripley is does
terrible things and I don't want to do spoiler
I think everybody needs to watch this movie it's
one of my favorite movies especially if you want
to have a main character who who does bad things
but we're still connected to him and we're still
watching him going don't do it tom it's just like
don't but we know what he wants because it's set
up so clearly at the beginning that we feel for
him and we understand him and we are riveted
by his journey because as he does one terrible
thing after another we keep wanting him to have a
chance to take it all back and to make the right
choice and so even though he's an anti-hero we're
like please don't do anything bad please make
choose the person who loves you he didn't choose
it's just it's a brilliant movie because we we
hate the guy but we have complete empathy for that
person and if we're connected to the character
that way we will follow that person to the end
of the movie or the end of the tv show because
we're interested we we and we care and we
understand why they're doing what they do
pat at what point does empathy have
to be present in the story so if we
have a character that's unlikable but eventually
we determine okay we understand why they're doing
what they're doing is there a certain point where
the empathy meter has to kick in for the audience
yeah I actually think the empathy meter has
to kick in on page one like that connection
needs to be established immediately in the
story and if it's not we're gonna struggle
to connect to that person and follow them
especially if they're kind of an anti-hero
main character so for example in in the talented
Mr Ripley where Tom Ripley is an anti-hero
the the filmmaker and the writer
I think it's Anthony Mangala
works really hard on page one to
establish why he wants what he wants
he wants to be seen by people in power he wants
to play music and he's basically living in poverty
and we see him in this environment and we see him
yearning to be part of this glittery rich crowd
and so because we are so connected to him around
that because all of us have been wanting to be
part of something that maybe we can never be
part of right we can all relate to that and
so later when he starts doing terrible things to
stay part of that group that that glittery crowd
we totally understand why he's doing it and
it's so deeply embedded in our understanding
of the character that he can pretty much do
anything and we will still follow him through
this story so no matter what kind of movie you're
writing even if it's an anti-hero type of movie
you have to establish that connection
or that understanding pretty quickly
in the story what is the mystery that
sometimes makes writing seem so daunting
if only I knew what the mystery
was there's so many mysteries um
okay so the way I look at writing is like there's
the craft right there's the things that you can
learn like how to create a great character like
what's the react structure how to write a great
scene what's good dialogue how to tell a visual
story all that kind of stuff you can kind of
learn that stuff right and you can you can sort
of absorb it and practice it and get better at it
but the second half of writing is this weird
alchemy and I love that you described it as
magical because it is magic it feels like magic
sometimes and sometimes you can't control that
magical side like this other side that's
like I made an outline and I have my act
breaks and here's the midpoint like that you
can control on the page but the part of writing
that uses the right side of your brain that is
really holistic and intuitive and connecting it's
it feels like magic because at times when at least
when I'm writing I feel like I'm literally just
taking dictation from someone that I'm just typing
these people are talking to me and I'm writing
down what they what they say and there are other
times where I'm writing scenes where it's like
enter scene she wants this she does this to get
it there is so it's very kind of like practical
and I think it's this magical what we call
the magical side of writing that makes it
feel really really daunting and something that we
cannot control and that we want to be able to go
every time I sit down to write it's magical and
it's not and the one thing that I've discovered
about the magical side of writing is that it
won't happen unless you're sitting in the chair
and and it's not there the whole time and it
does seem daunting because you can't control it
but if you put in the work if you sit
in the chair if you show up every day
and create that time for me like if I work
at the same time every day that becomes magic
because I have created a ritual where I sit
down I turn on my computer I have my coffee
I post a writing quote every morning so I look
and I find a writing quote that applies to me
what am I struggling with today and then I
find that quote and then I post it and then
I sit down and I start to write and because
I've created these routines around my writing
the magic is attracted to it and so it doesn't
always go well I mean I have days where I write
nothing or I write one page and it's really bad
and I know it's bad but I found that this idea
that it's daunting can actually take on its own
dark power that there's this thing out there and
it's magic and I don't have access to it because
writing for me is hard it's hard for everyone it's
hard how many drafts have you written of this
thing you still have to try to find that that
that thing that once it clicks it's like oh I
found it but in order to attach to that magic you
have to actually be sitting in your chair and just
showing up every single day so and I love that you
mentioned mentioned Richard Walter earlier in our
comments because he was my screenwriting teacher
but he used to he used to say this this thing
in class which I thought was really great
which is there's no such thing as writer's block
that is something that we actually create in our
minds as a way of avoiding facing things in our
writing or in our script if we're writing about
something that's really emotionally close to us
it's like suddenly writing becomes really hard and
now I'm worried about the person I'm writing about
and they're going to read the script and I need to
change the character and I think as writers we
have to stop thinking about it as writer's block
because we create the block we create the block
because of other things that are going on and so
all we have to do and all we really can do is
show up in the chair and write and again this
is just my experience I'm sure other writers have
had different experiences the magic does not come
very often at all but when it comes it's like
amazing and suddenly things start to make sense
and you didn't understand what the script was
about and why is this character doing this thing
suddenly you go oh my god this is why she's
doing it and this is what she would do next
because she wants and so that that that connective
side of your of your brain is the magic I think
and in order to let it do its job you just
have to drag your left side of your brain
that made the outline into the chair and work
diligently and ho and just wait for it to come
so thunder's not going to crash outside your
window while you're I mean not every time once
okay I actually find thunder crashes inside me
like my anxiety is its own daunting thing to deal
with around writing and if I could if I could tame
my anxiety and really get it under control I feel
like the dauntingness of writing would be far
lessened for me and I don't know I'm sure other
writers struggle with anxiety as well but it's
super it can be very it can take over your brain
and then you start thinking about other things and
stuff and so again creating those rituals where
you sit down at your desk and you have your cup of
coffee or your tea or whatever and you have little
colored pencils like that you really make it
almost religious because what happens is when you
you create those patterns the minute you sit down
your brain starts to go into that mode of like now
it's writing time now I'm going to write so yeah
I don't think you can depend on inspiration or
like a thunderstorm to inspire you or whatever
you just have to be diligent and show up
and and do the work it's great because I have
this quote here that we were saving for the end
but it it's funny that I chose this I saw on your
blog that you loved Joan Didion yeah and that you
were watching a documentary I think she's had at
least one or two yeah and so she says here don't
excuse me do not whine do not complain work harder
spend more time alone and this is from her 2011
memoir blue nights yes so yeah I don't know
that's that's kind of fitting it sounds like it
that's weird that I just that's the truth that
is the truth in that one sentence as writers and
especially as women like it's hard to find time
alone and it's hard to prioritize your writing
especially if you're still working in a regular
job and you're trying to sort of your writing
but it's you have kids or family or whatever
it's very hard to prioritize that alone time
but if you don't do it you won't get the work done
and so I love what she says about work hard carve
that space out in your life to be alone because in
order to get your pages done you really do have to
be alone and you do whether you like music playing
or whatever environment you like to write in you
have to act like it's really important and you
have to prioritize it because if you don't it'll
be the first thing to get shoved away when my
when my kids I mean they're young adults now I
have two boys but when they were babies I used
to just set my coffee pot to like four a.m
would set my coffee pot I would set my alarm I
would get up at 4 a.m it was completely quiet
everybody was asleep I would go into the kitchen
I would get my cup of coffee and I would just go
into the den and I would write until six and then
everyone started screaming and crying and needing
me and then I could start my day and I could
do meetings or whatever I had to do but I had
carved out that time in the darkness by
myself with a single lamp on with my computer
to get my work done now I was wiped out by
4 p.m like I was like a liv like a zombie
walking through my life but I kind of arranged my
day so that I didn't really need to do anything
that required a lot of thought at the
end of the day so it worked out for me
but at first it was really hard to make that
commitment and go I'm getting up at four
in the morning because it was just like these kids
are killing me oh my god it's just motherhood was
like a big a big thing and I just found when
I when I had those two hours in the morning
got my work done I was so much happier the rest
of the day I interacted with my children in a
positive way and most importantly I got I got my
pages done and so how do you carve out that alone
alone time do you need to actually get out of
your house sometimes your house is so busy that
there's no way to work there so is there a
coffee shop that you love where you can go
and just sit there with your latte and stay
there for an hour and a half one thing that I
that I've read about which is really interesting
and hopefully helpful for the people who
are your viewers is that they've done studies
where people who write at the same time every day
and create this pattern this habit are much more
productive and tend to finish their projects
my maya angelou used to she couldn't work
in her house so she would like she had a
room reserved at a hotel and like she would
show up there at 9am in her little hotel room
she would write until noon get her
pages done and then in the afternoon
she'd go to lunch do whatever she if she had
meetings or whatever she needed to do or read
whatever she needed to do in the afternoons she
could do but she her she went to her office like
in this hotel room and created that ritual for
herself away from her family so that she could
get her work done what about the stigma of well
you're being selfish because people need you
my friend meg lafove talks about lava all the
time which I think is so great because it's it's
that emotional stuff that triggers you and that
stops you and when you're writing about it in
your story it's like it's alive for you maybe not
even in a positive way because it's so triggering
or whatever does do people say it's selfish for
people to go to the bank and work as a teller
do people say it's selfish to hello kitty sorry
now I'm feeling she usually is quiet so she's
just like I know I think she's saying mama I love
it what about the idea that it's selfish to set
time for oneself for something like writing
when people might need you well people are
always going to need you and I think the
thing that we all have to struggle with as
writers is finding that time for ourselves
and like I said really prioritizing it and
believing in ourselves that it is important
and so I always wonder like does anyone
say like the guy who goes to work at the bank
is like selfish because he's like doing his job
or somebody who works in a supermarket who's the
cashier are they selfish they're they're doing
their job and if you are a writer and whether
you're earning money as a writer or not if you're
writing you're a writer and so that's your job
and so if you have to fit it in around actually
earning a living that's great but I don't know
if any of your viewers have had this experience
but like when I don't write I don't feel good
I get mad I feel testy I'm like upset like
I just feel like I'm not myself and I get
very like angry and I start to hold on to
things because I'm actually not honoring who I
am and expressing myself in the way that I was
meant to so instead of looking at setting aside
time to write as being kind of a selfish thing
it's a thing that's actually necessary to you
as a human being to actualize and be who you
are meant to be and so it's important it's as
important as anything and if you give yourself
that time to honor who you are and that you
love to write and that writing gives you joy
and allows you to express yourself everything else
in your life will be better because of it and so
anyone who says you're selfish I think you need
to think about how that's about them and not about
you and what you're doing why are they trying
to stop you from doing the thing that you love
excellent yeah and lastly again what are some of
the items as part of the ritual so you said you
have a cup of coffee or tea you sit down at a
certain time and you have these colored pencils
common colored pencils I've got my little like
I'm a left brainer so like everything is organized
kind of like I that's who I am as a person so yeah
I get my my coffee is key back when I was in film
school I used to smoke cigarettes and so I finally
was like oh my god I gotta quit cigarettes they're
really bad I was having a cough and everything so
I'm like okay I'm gonna stop smoking so I stopped
smoking I got the patch I could not write because
the smoking was so connected to my ability to be
able to like think and be creative I had created
this connection that I had to actually sever that
connection it was really hard but now coffee is
my vice so I have my cup of coffee I have my mug
I sit down at my computer I use pencils I love
pencils they wear down you can erase things you
can they disappear like as you sort of sharpen
them and keep writing they disappear which is
kind of proof of of all the stuff that's come out
of my pencil I can like see it because now it's a
nub I have colored pencils to underline certain
things with certain characters in my outline
so that I can track who how their arc is
building in my outline and it's just a way of me
a way of me organizing my writing time that
that it's so ritualized that I don't have to
think about what's next it's like that part of
the practical part of writing is just like I'm
in the scene I'm writing I've got the coffee
which makes my brain feel like it's writing time
it's writing time here comes the caffeine and
I don't know just these rituals really help me
I do not listen to music when I'm writing I cannot
because it's distracting to me I can I can listen
to music if it doesn't have lyrics if there are
words I start listening to the lyrics which is
problematic for me my husband's a screenwriter
and he creates a soundtrack for whatever he's
writing and he's got it blasting in his ears
and like he's like and I'm just like oh my god
could you be quiet my process is different than
yours but and he when he when he writes dialogue
he's just he's saying the words out loud and
so he has this very kind of like extroverted
version of his process but mine is really quiet
and just kind of like focused with my coffee and
my silence and I get up every hour I walk around
which helps me if I sit for too long I start to
actually ruin the stuff that I wrote so I find
getting up and moving my body is really helpful
but yeah I've just created these rituals that
signal to my brain it's time to work and that's
been really helpful what's interesting about the
cigarette and not I mean I wasn't a huge smoker
but there and cancer is not sexy and emphysema is
not sexy but there is a there's a very sensual way
that one can think with a cigarette oh yeah that's
whether it's parisian or whatever I mean there's a
way to exhale and each one means different things
so I could see how that would be a difficult thing
aside from the nicotine well and I didn't realize
that I had been smoking so much when I was writing
and working but it had that connection had been
made and just the breathing in and the breathing
out and the nicotine which then I substituted with
caffeine I think there's definitely a stimulant
effect that I like when I'm working but boy
was I was I shocked when I realized like
I can't think anymore without smoking and I have
to find something else to kind of substitute
in for that yeah and it's also too the way you
ash some there's just little effects fingers right
like it blows and you're you're just like in
this cocoon of fog which I loved yeah yeah and
all my clothes smelled like smoke I thought
I think at that time I thought it was very
romantic it's probably disgusting but yeah well
there was a time and a place for some of that
and it was also you could commiserate with other
smokers it was a very social thing but I could
see how with writing and also having an alcoholic
beverage like certain things would play into that
writer persona that's right that would be hard
to break but that's right I could never write
with alcohol it's just I'm such a lightweight
it just doesn't work for me but things that are
stimulate stimulants like cigarettes and coffee
have always been kind of like my my bad friends
my friends that I know I shouldn't be hanging out
with right right that your mother warned you about
she did but they were so much fun they were so
much fun yeah how do you help writers find the
emotional spine of their story yeah oh that's a
great question so the emotional spine is the most
important thing it is the most important thing
and oftentimes it's one of the last things that
becomes really clear because sometimes you have
to write through a bunch of stuff to actually
realize what the emotional spine is of your story
but one way that I work with writers on finding
their emotional spine of their story is by using
the hero's journey and the reason I actually like
that story model is I think it's the deepest kind
of psychological model and it really is about fear
and facing whatever darkness we have in
ourselves in pursuing what we want and so
what I do with writers when they're sometimes
writers have a really great story but I'm like
what do they want what's the emotional growth
like what's their flaw what's their problem
we actually do kind of talk through this idea of
the hero's journey and often what's missing is
like a fear like some people write main characters
that are like perfect like they're just good
people and they always do the right thing and
it's like after a while it's kind of like wow
the secondary characters are really fun and
interesting and your main character is just
kind of like dull and so how do you take some
of that juice that you've given your secondary
characters and really create a main character
who's complicated and flawed and it's so good
to have a character that has a flaw because then
they make mistakes which creates more conflict and
then they do things out of fear which allows us to
understand them more deeply and create structure
so which creates structure for us so so what
I do is we sort of talk through okay what
is your character afraid of like what is their
emotional need let's say it's love and connection
and let's just say they're afraid of being
rejected just to pick them a really simple example
right and so I encourage writers to think about
why are they afraid of being rejected like what
happened to them what happened to them and to
actually write that scene even if it's not going
to be in the movie like what is the scene where
they were rejected in some really primal deep way
then they are grounded in that character's
backstory and they don't have to do a
flashback but everything they write is going to
be infused with that thing that happened to them
and it's going to infuse the way that they
interact with the world and how their fear gets
triggered right and so a great character let's
say let's say they got rejected in their past
and they're going along in their life
and they want love but they don't have it
and the call to adventure is oh my god that person
that's my person but they refuse the call because
they're too afraid of being rejected right again
so we're getting internal conflict and then maybe
I can do it this time maybe I can actually put
myself out there so they talk to their friends
or they get some guidance from somebody and like
in the meeting the mentor section of the hero's
journey and they they realize like if I do if I if
I do this then maybe I'll i'll be able to be with
that person and so they decide to go for it and
they commit to like I'm gonna I'm gonna make that
person love me and they set off on their quest and
now we're in act two and they go for their goal
and there's people who are helping them like yeah
yeah he really is really into you let's do this
and someone people are trying to stop stop her
I'm just gonna say it's a she at this point like
you're not his type he likes this other girl
like putting that fear so that that fear is
externalized through a character that can press
on that character in the story and but they really
want that person so bad and so they keep moving
forward and the middle of act two in the hero's
journey is called approach to the inmost cave and
the way to think about your story in this section
is that in the cave is the treasure which is that
person that she wants to fall in love with her
right and she really wants that person really
badly but the cave is made up of her fear
because she wants him she's she's going to go for
him but as she's going for him she gets more and
more vulnerable and so her emotions get triggered
and she's afraid and maybe a lot of times in a
romantic comedy or a romance story the midpoint
in act 2 is a kiss or some kind of intimate
connection and that triggers let's just say for
our character that we just made up right now
that triggers her fear like oh my god I'm so she
pushes away again to protect herself and the other
person's like wait what's going on I thought
we and she's and then she she does something
even more sort of out of her fear and now she's
at the end of act two she's completely alone
she's blown it and she's failed and that person
is with someone else and she's never ever gonna
have that person love her okay but then maybe the
mentor comes in or maybe she discovers something
that allows her to believe she has a chance
one more chance and so she decides I'm gonna
I'm gonna try to get him one more time and
that launches her into act three and then
there's that race or she's trying to get to the
person whatever and in that scene she has to face
her fear like like the classic cliche
version of this is like she's running
to the airport oh my god he's leaving on a
play she gets there and there goes the plane
he's gone right so that s that death of her
dream at the end of act two where she failed
is reenacted once more and it's like oh my
god she's not going to get what she wants
but then she turns and there he is he didn't get
on the plane or he goes on the plane and he leaves
and in a scene that happens after that they meet
again by accident or something and she tells him
how she feels and she opens herself up and she's
completely vulnerable which is her growth and
her transformation and because she's grown
and because she's revealed her true feelings
he's like hell yeah I'll be with you and she gets
what she wants so the hero's journey by creating
this idea of the fear in in the character
and actually grounding it in a real thing
that's something you can play with in the story to
create emotional growth for the main character and
another way that I like to think about creating
emotional structure for the for the character in
the story is that how are they going to change and
this may be a Richard Walter thing again I don't
know if I'm pulling this from Richard I probably
am but he I think in his book he talks about
this idea of like a bow and arrow and if
you're let's just say at the end of this
movie that you're writing that she's gonna stand
before him and say how much she loves him and be
really vulnerable so that's the that's where
the arrow lands right so in creating the arc
the emotional arc you want to pull that that
arrow back as far away from that as you can
so that there it looks like there's no way
she can ever be vulnerable with anybody
okay so that you're you're creating these this
polarity in the story of how who she is at
the beginning what her belief system is about
herself and the world and then how it changes
at the end and then you're kind of building
the emotional journey between those two poles
so that's another way to think about creating
emotional structure as you were speaking I it
was taking me back to 16 candles oh my god so
I mean I realize I'm going back a few years
but I'm so I'm thinking of the Molly Ringwald
character yes and she's feeling left out
because her sister's wedding right yeah and and
everybody's busy yes and then she has the crush
on Jake Jake right yeah you all remember Jake and
he's got like sort of the cheerleader girlfriend
and in her mind he's totally unattainable but
he was perfect right and so she's at the dance
and then she gets sort of this unwanted attention
but it's part mentor right the the one forgive me
it was Anthony Michael Hall yes okay yeah and and
he was awesome in the film and and he's kind of a
mentor but he's also trying to pick her up yeah
and and so and then yeah we don't want to spoil
it even though the movie is 30 years okay all
right it's it's been it's been lit but it's so
then there's the moment where there he is yes and
it's the awkward and I forget he's got his car he
probably has like this or whatever yeah yeah and
so and then they have the weird conversation and
yeah yeah so I'm thinking of I'm thinking of that
that's exactly how yeah the all is lost right at
the end of act two we have it where the the person
is with someone else and then the character has
to kind of relive it in the climax again right and
that character of Jake it's so interesting because
I watched that movie a few months
ago his character is so problematic
oh is he oh yeah I mean it's but it's fascinating
to watch it from 2021 back and and going oh
yeah we thought that was okay or whatever a
lot of the stuff that happens in that movie
but that's exactly what I'm talking about
that emotional structure of like there he is
and yeah and sometimes the way that that emotional
growth happens in the climax is also like
the the hero is sort of in the climax it looks
like they're they're they're not going to get what
they want again that person's gone or whatever
but because of what they've learned on the journey
they do something emotionally they never
could have done at the beginning of the movie
and because they do it in that moment they
actually get what they want and they might
not get it in the want in the way that they wanted
or thought they would get it back then but it's it
could be in a new way that is actually even better
than the way they thought they were gonna get it
how does a writer find the central thematic spark
of their screenplay the central thematic spark oh
yeah that's like the magic that's part of
the magic that we were talking about I think
for me and this is just my experience
is theme comes like almost last like I
it's not it's not a spark in the sense of like a
catalyst for an idea for me it really is something
that comes after I've kind of worked a lot and and
basically thought oh that's the theme and then no
that's not the theme and then that's the theme and
that's not the theme and suddenly the theme is the
thing for me that comes last it comes for me as a
writer when I have figured out who the characters
are what they want deeply what their fears are
and as I see them struggling to kind of get
what they want and again it really happens for me
toward the end of the writing process in revision
because I may think I have a theme starting out
and it's never that never ends up what it's about
because as I explore and excavate my characters it
it it appears and it does feel like magic because
for me it's about like oh my god this movie's
really about this I had no idea that it was
about this and I work with a lot of writers too
who think they know what their theme is and it
turns out that what they're writing is not what
they started out thinking their movie was about
and it's evolved into something else and so that
those little things that they thought were really
important at the beginning of the writing process
end up falling away in favor of whatever is now
sort of taking hold because of the character
development in in the story so for me it's really
it's part of the magic and I don't I don't really
even know what my movie's about when I when I
start anymore I just I trust that I will know and
I don't I don't know I have I have found when I
was first starting out writing that when I started
with a theme like this is a movie about blank that
it kind of became wooden because I was basically
just writing to fulfill some prescriptive kind of
tenet or something I don't know but when I
just trust that I don't need to know my theme
I'll wait for it it will come to me usually it
does sometimes it doesn't and I have to have other
people read it to tell me what do you think this
is about because I just kind of get lost in the
weeds yeah arthur miller I love this the way he
that we the way he worked with theme he had this
little building outside of his house that was like
his writing shed I'm sure it was really beautiful
so calling it a shed is probably wrong but he
would go out there and he obviously was working
on a typewriter right because it was the 50s or
whatever and he would he would start writing his
plays and he said that in the writing process
he would suddenly realize what the theme was
and it was usually when he was kind of in
the middle of writing his play and then
he would type up the theme and put it above the
typewriter and that guided the rest of his writing
so he would find his theme in the middle of the
process of writing his plays and I'm sure there
are some people who have a theme at the beginning
and are able to kind of write to that but it it
to me it's kind of like it's magical like it's
it's you need to like leave it you need to let it
come to you because I think it's not even though a
theme feels intellectual like this movie is about
this I think theme theme is actually really like
from the heart it's a heart thing not like a brain
thing interesting yeah so it sounds like okay
because so much of writing seems like there's
these rules and you're connecting the dots to so
much but with this and I'm sure this is hard for
writers to do you're letting it go and you don't
know that's right that sounds like it's very
troublesome for writers so troublesome I mean and
and and obviously I'm not I'm not saying like go
crazy just write everything because it's a balance
like as a human being you have a left brain you
have a right brain organizer holistic intuitive
you need both of them to write a great script okay
and so part of it is magical but but part of it
is actually figuring out like creating a map for
yourself so that you don't go out into the weeds
now I know people I know a lot of people who don't
have outlines that's great like if you can do that
if you can figure it out and really let yourself
be completely free which to me is terrifying I
cannot be completely free because I will just
shut down it's too scary so I make a road map for
myself but then if I'm in there and it's like oh
this isn't working the way I thought it would and
this is boring like where should this where should
this be going and try to follow those things so
it's a balance of of structure and also allowing
for creative discovery in the writing process so
set your your sort of time your date with yourself
to sit down whether it's longhand or at the
typewriter have your little rituals your offerings
have your offerings and then start writing yeah
and then hopefully the thunder outside the window
brings what the theme is about or like you said
you you had other people look at your work and
say what they thought the theme was yeah I mean
when I get really stuck and basically people
come to me when they're stuck right like they've
looked at their script and they have taken it as
far as they can and they just need someone from
the outside to look at it we all do and so I have
people who look at my stuff I have a friend it's a
it's a girls group and it's writers it's producers
it's teachers it's storytellers and we're
friends it's a social group but we also share
our materials with each other if we need
feedback and it has been so helpful I just
I just wrote a book and I just felt like I don't
know what to do with this anymore and I gave
it to them and they were brutal and they're
extremely smart and I was just like oh my god
this is gold and I was able to go back in
there see what I couldn't see right because
they're coming and so I think we all as writers
need those people like who's our little circle
of who's our community of fellow writers that
we can go to and I'll read your stuff and you
read my stuff because yes writing is a lonely
sport but you can't always be alone you actually
do need people and that's the great thing about
working on a tv show because you're in a room
with lots of people now there are issues that
come out of that right like personalities and
all that stuff and I'm sure you've talked to
people who are tv writers who have stories to
tell about writing rooms but like the great thing
about it is you're in a room with other people
and I've worked as a story consultant at pixar
and one of the things I absolutely loved is
that like I'm in a room with other people and
we're working together on this story which is
not normally the way feature writers work which
is I'm a feature writer so it's it was it was
so fun to me to for for me to be in a room with
other people and so I want to advise people like
find your group like who are your people who
can you share this experience with and give
encouragement to and notes to and all that kind
of stuff because you can only take your project
so far alone you need other people yeah and so
with the talented mr ripley what is the theme
gosh the talented mr ripley is based on a book by
patricia highsmith and patricia highsmith is one
of my favorite writers she's extremely dark
and it's all about twisted human psychology
and she wrote the price of salt which be which
actually phyllis naj turned into the amazing
movie carol right so she wrote
about not just super dark things but
but other other things as well but the talented
mr ripley honestly I don't know what the theme is
it it it it it doesn't I think the thing I love
about the movie and the book is that it won't
fit into our prescribed little boxes of theme or
meaning because the main character is this guy
who's doing everything a main character should
never do and yet we're riveted by him and so
we're able to kind of see the humanity in the
darkness in the dark psychology and so I think
what I'm attracted to in her is that and for
me that's the theme it's like wow monsters are
human too and they are just like me in some ways
so that's why I love her stuff and her writing
it's it's so unique and so specific that you you
you can try to kind of like box her in to like
what we understand as like this kind of movie or
this kind of book or this kind of thing but like
she will not be boxed which is what makes
her great but she faced a lot of criticism
especially at that time absolutely and her
politics were terrible I mean she really was
was in many ways not a great human being but as
a writer like I have to admire how she just did
what everyone said don't do it don't do it and yet
and in doing that created these really compelling
characters that we should buy all rights not like
and not feel empathy toward and I think she pulls
it off I'm not talking about carol I'm talking
about ripley which is a completely different
character but yeah she just breaks the rules
which I love yeah why do you teach your students
three different types of story structures so you
have the hero's journey the three-act structure
and then something that was new to me which is the
Jules Selbo 11-step model yeah so there are all
these different story structure models out there
in the world and they just have different terms
but they're all basically kind of
the same approach to story structure
so and every writer has a different process and
a way of thinking about stories so I think it's
really good to expose yourself as a writer to all
the different models and see okay which one helps
me and I think the important thing to remember is
it's their forms not formulas it's not something
you should follow like paint by number like
here's page 30 this is where the turning point
mid six midpoint is on page 60 like like I really
use these story models as inspiration rather than
some sort of set of rules that I have to follow
and so I like to give my writers different tools
to put in their toolbox and then to use the ones
that are helpful to them and there are there are
three that I really like and there's others
too that are really amazing but I just find
it I don't want to give people too many things
which just makes them crazy and confused including
myself by the way so I like the hero's journey
which we've already talked about and I use
that which is the ordinary world the call to
adventure the refusal to the call out of fear
meeting the mentors crossing the threshold blah
blah so so for those those people that are really
interested in psychological storytelling and
emotional journeys I think that's that's the
number one one and that story model is fascinating
because joseph campbell who actually identified
that pattern of storytelling he studied myths and
fairy tales across all different kinds of cultures
and across all recorded history and it's the same
pattern so it it and he sort of likens characters
in these myths and fairy tales to those that carl
jung found in our unconscious brain and it's like
I think the reason this story model is so
powerful is it comes from our human brain
our need to have a story told in a certain way
where we're processing our own fears and our own
struggles so I love that story model it helps me
a lot again not a formula it's a form you can move
those and shift those phases around or draw or not
have a phase it's up to you to use it creatively
and you can see that pattern in hollywood
movies you can also see it in more independent
slightly experimental films you can find traces
of it so it just depends how much you want to
embrace that in your in your structure and then I
also talk a little bit about three act structure
which is kind of the way everybody talks about
story structure ordinary world inciting incident
act one turning point midpoint end of act
two where the everything falls apart and then
I'm gonna try one more time and then climax and
then resolution and that's just a really simple
way to think of feature writing which is mostly
what I focus on with writers so there's that model
and then there's the jewel sell bow model and
I'm going to get my cheat my channel oh please
yeah yeah this was new to me but I jules selbo
wrote a book I can't remember the name of it
but it's it's j u l e s e elbow s-e-l-b-o and she
is wonderful and this this way of telling future
stories is so simple and so clear and I just find
it really helpful so I'll share that with you
and again if if you find that this is like
working for you and you really are attracted
to it like get her book because it explains it in
much more detail but she basically says there are
11 steps in a feature film the first step is the
character's overall want and why so you establish
through action what they want and why they want
it and then the character logically goes for it
so they take action to try to get that thing that
they want but the character is somehow denied
okay they they that's not gonna work they can't
they can't get it that way but the character gets
a second opportunity to achieve their overall
want but there's danger around that second
opportunity like it's kind of a shady way maybe
it's not on the up and up but there's some danger
around it either emotionally or physically okay
but they want it so badly at the end of act one
they go for it they decide to go for it again
these these forms are the same like they're just
different language around the same turning points
and stuff but at the end of act one the character
decides to go for it and now we're in act two
right and so all goes well they're going for
it look they're getting what they want oh my god
but something happens in the middle of the script
and one thing I would love to share with
your viewers is this idea of the midpoint
sometimes the midpoint people think of it as
like something happens out of the blue that
that causes everything to fall apart or it's like
a false victory and then they have to deal with
its false or whatever but I always think the best
mid-points are a moment where the character just
like everything's going okay they're getting what
they want but then they get to that cave and it's
like they're in that cave and their fear is around
them and they make a decision out of fear that
causes everything to fall apart for them they
go back to their old pattern and that actively
gives them like they drive that midpoint and and
causes everything to fall apart which in jewels
11-step structures called all falls apart right so
all falls apart looks like they're going to fail
and then at the end of act two there's a
crisis where they again have to make a decision
or commitment do they go for a new strategy
do they give up what do they do usually
they decide to try again and that decision or
that crisis decision drives them into act three
and then we have this climax where it's
the final attempt to get what they want and
again usually we have a transformation right
they do something they never could have done
back in act one they get what they want and then
the last phase she calls truth the truth comes
out to make things right and this is where
that the character discovers something new
about her world she has some new insight about
herself and that usually has the power to heal
whatever was broken back at the beginning of the
story and so what I love about this this story
model is that it's really goal driven it's like
they want something they decide to go for it they
get blocked they get a second opportunity I'm
afraid I want it so much I'm going to go for it
it's just it allows you to really find that
goal for your character and let them pursue
that in the story that's awesome and who was Jules
Selbo is an incredible writer I can't say enough
great things about her she's a friend she's
a wonderful woman she's super talented writer
I met her as just a colleague as a writer
and a person who worked with screenwriting
students she's written a bunch of different movies
she did a lot of animation she's writing novels
now she just wrote a new kind of like detective
novel that just came out and she's phenomenal
and I think she's still teaching but she really
just looked at all this material out there and
she said I'm going to make up my own version of
this that's really simple it's really character
and goal driven and I've used that 11 step story
structure a lot in my own work and with clients
now you have a film that you wrote and directed
that starred Alicia Silverstone yes and it's a
True Crime it's called True Crime okay yes please
don't watch it it's not very good oh no no no I
would love to tell my True Crime story if people
are interested if any if any of your viewers
are interested in being filmmakers in addition to
being writers like wanting to make your own films
because I actually started out and I wanted to be
a director and I went to ucla film school I was
in the directing program there I got my MFA there
and I was positive that that's what I wanted to do
until I directed a movie called true and I
just found it was it was a great experience
like I learned so much but I also realized
I'm not a director like I don't enjoy being
kind of the focus of everybody's questions
and lots of stress and all that stuff I
really realized like oh my gosh I had such
a great time writing the script like I'm the
right I'm the writer I'm not the director but
it was it was a great experience and what it
taught me as a writer is because because I was
directing it too and it was pretty low budget
at the time we had like 18 days to shoot it so
it was kind of crazy what I what I found is and I
wish I had known this before I actually directed
it is how important it is if you're actually
making your own scripts like you're and you're
kind of doing it DIY I mean I had a studio that I
think the budget was 1.2 million dollars which at
the time was it was a decent low budget movie but
what I wish I had known and I wish I had listened
to people who told me is make it contained don't
have a lot of different locations really boil your
script down to only the scenes that you absolutely
need to tell your story because what ended up
happening is that we would have company moves and
I just I every day I lost scenes where the
producers were just like we can't shoot that scene
because we're not enough time and so it was
just very frustrating to to watch my story
eventually it kind of makes sense in the editing
room we had to kind of rewrite the movie to
to fix all the things that we couldn't shoot
but and it kind of worked out but what was
great about it is I learned I didn't want to be
a director I really learned that I am a writer
through and through I like being alone yes I like
being with other people in a room too but I do not
like being on a set and being in charge of a bunch
of people it was just extremely uncomfortable for
me sure I mean sometimes the idea of something
sounds wonderful and the title of it and then once
you actually get into doing it then you realize
that okay this isn't for me but is it for me I'm
gonna get through this and I had done it in film
school I had directed several films which I loved
doing but it was on a much smaller scale it was
just my friends and I making a movie and it was
great but when it became this big thing I just
realized I don't have the temperament to really
deal with all the stress sure sure now
what prompted you to write the story
the that story oh that was that this is actually
might be really interesting for your viewers I
got out of film school and I said I was in the
directing program so I had a couple short films
that I had made but my agent said you need to
write something you need to write a feature and
I was like okay what should I write about I have
no idea and I remembered back to something that
happened to me when I was a little girl when I was
like 9 or 10 years old I was at my grandparents
house and I was I don't know I was looking for
something and I went to my grandfather's closet
and I found the stack of true detective magazines
which back in the day were like the way we have
True Crime now it's all over television well back
in the day it was kind of this secret thing there
were these magazines right and I was like oh
what are these magazines I'm like a 10 year old
oh and I opened them up and it's like literally
photos of like dead bodies with like black
strips over their eyes and I was just like
ah what is this and then I was reading and
they described like how the person got murdered
and how the detectives went after them and figured
out who had committed the crime and everything and
part of me was like this whole ugly world of like
the real world was opened up to me but I also was
like this is cool like detective stuff like I like
this but my grandfather was like patty and I was
like oh put it away pretend like I never thought
what I'm innocent but I also it really ignited in
me this interest in True Crime which I still have
but as I was thinking of what I want to write I
was like oh maybe I could write about like that
thing of finding those magazines so I ended
up fictionalizing it and I just made it about
a high school girl who's obsessed with True
Crime magazines and a girl at her high school
gets murdered and she decides she's gonna find
out who the killer was so it's kind of like a
nancy drew kind of beast b-level movie about this
girl who wants to find the killer and it's kind of
a coming-of-age story really but it came from my
own experience and a lot of the stuff that I write
it it may not be technically literally what
happened to me but there's always something
in there that did happen to me and so I think when
you're looking for a story you always want to have
that personal connection somehow because that's
kind of where the juice is for you as a writer
especially if you're scared to write it that's
a good thing well the million-dollar question
is what was the theme oh the theme I think the
theme ended up being be careful what you wish for
be careful what you wish for interesting
you think the way the world works
little girl you have no idea so it's kind of dark
it was kind of a dark theme sure yeah when you
were writing a story what type of structure do
you use most often hero's journey that's that's
I use that structure probably the most because
again it helps me kind of track the emotions of
my character what are they afraid of what do they
want how do they have to kind of face that fear
I'm writing something now and I decided to do
something I should probably not have done which
is like I'm gonna go free I'm gonna I'm gonna
try to just start writing this thing and I just I
just barfed it out which is which is actually
good for me because I need to actually do that
because I tend to be over here in my left brain a
lot and so I barfed this thing out and it's like
it's like 70 pages I'm not even really sure
what it is except it is a detective themed thing
but I read through it again and now I'm
going oh okay I think this is what it is
like this one little part over here
that's where like the the juice lies
and so now I'm taking that little juicy thing
and going okay how can I sort of approach the
rewrite with more of a map and a view
to kind of now what I think it's about
and so usually I just I make a very loose outline
it's not detailed it really just says kind of like
the major action beats like what happens in the
inciting incident or the call to adventure and
whether the person pushes away from it out of fear
and then what happens next to kind of pull them in
but I want to leave it kind of not not detailed
because then that leaves things for me to discover
when I'm writing so is it harder for you to not
be organized and invested in structure yes it's
very hard for me to be free that's why I
think I gave myself that challenge of just
pat let step away from the outline step
away and I needed to kind of just go
blah and when I did that I actually found really
interesting things happening that I didn't expect
and again that's where I found that little spark
that was like oh this is this is what it's about
so yeah for me and I think writers should
challenge themselves like what's hard for you
make yourself do that thing make yourself do it
even if you're scared of doing it make yourself do
it and then get more comfortable with it because
there's something in there that's scaring you
and that's good you need to go there you need to
go into your own approach to the cave as a writer
so I work with a lot of people who are
writing kind of memoir book books I work
with authors as well and a lot of the times
they're like I think I'm going to change this
so that it's not about the person so that they
when they and I'm like what this is your draft
no one's going to read it but you write every
single thing that happened write the truth
because if you're holding back we're going to know
that you're being untruthful with us now after
you get out this version where everything the
truth is everything everybody did is on the page
then you can go back and modulate and figure
out but you have to tell the truth and
if you're writing a script that is based
on experience and you find yourself going
I don't want to write that scene
you got it you got to go there
that's the scene that's what your movie's about
and you're afraid to go there because like there's
something in there that you just don't want to
look at or yeah and so for a right-brained writer
who's messy and chaotic and everything's sort of
based on intuition then what would scare them is
probably structure rules numbered sequence right
and and I've worked with a lot of right-brained
writers and it's always it's just a matter of
usually they don't they it's not like they do
a 180 and suddenly become like I'm have detailed
outlines usually it's just getting them to a place
that is comfortable for them to organize
something so that they don't get lost in the weeds
their right brain is their strength it's like
their superpower but it can also lead them into
the darkness and down tangents and out into
the woods and then they don't know how to get
back and oh my god where's the flashlight so
helping them find something that's comfortable
in terms of organization but not too detailed
and sometimes it's even just a matter of talking
through the character's emotional journey and how
they change that gives them enough in their head
to kind of guide their writing as their writing so
maybe they don't even write an outline they just
kind of talk it through so that they kind of know
where they're going wouldn't know anything about
it yeah is that your I I'm your right brain yeah
yeah tried and true yeah yeah check out the hero's
journey okay yeah I love the interview that Bill
Moyers did with Joseph it's so excellent and and
he just the two of them together were just
a great team oh yeah yeah in terms of uh
the interview yeah that's a great that's a great
piece of I'm so glad they recorded it right for
posterity wouldn't you say that if writers and
filmmakers follow these structures that their
films will be predictable that's often something
we get in our comments yes and well this is why
Hollywood produces these formulaic
movies yes yes that's always the danger
that's always the danger and when you're watching
a formulaic movie when exactly what's going to
happen in the climax on 10 minutes in that that
movie is gonna fulfill those expectations right
so there's a couple of ways to approach that idea
of cliche and predictability if you're writing the
predictability doesn't just lie along structure
lines it also lies along genre lines that certain
genres hold have conventions that become familiar
patterns right and so the trick is to look
at these forms whether it's a structural form
like the hero's journey or three-act structure
as a form and not a formula that it's just there
to give you some landmarks to help work through
the story with your character and then if you're
writing in a specific genre if I'm writing a
horror movie and it doesn't have scary stuff
in it like that's going to be a failure so I
have to understand the genre I'm working in and
what the expectations of my audience are and I
have to deliver that in a way that feels fresh the
audience is coming to your movie with expectations
of the conventions of that genre they're going to
want to see in the romantic comedy the mistaken
identity or the misheard thing or the kiss at the
end or whatever so how do you deliver those things
without making them feel like boring and cliched
and well well trod right so that's your challenge
as a writer to to either embrace the conventions
and make them feel fresh or kind of subvert them I
just watched a movie last week it's not a great
movie but it's it's good and it's it's very
like lovely the mitchells versus the machines on
netflix it's an animated movie and one thing they
did at the ending which I thought was really
funny is in the hero's journey the way that
they kind of combated this idea of like and now
this is gonna happen and now this is gonna happen
what happens is in the hero's journey in the
climax when you're facing off against the bad guy
it looks like you're gonna die oh no they died but
then they live so what they did in the movie is
they face the robots and the family's fighting
and they they beat the robots and it's like
they destroy the bad guy and it's like yay but
then the main character has fallen into this pit
and the family gathers around it's like oh my god
katie no and it looks like she's dead and she just
pops up she goes just kidding they're mocking
that story moment in the pharaoh's journey and
so they're acknowledging it and they're making
fun of it and we laugh and so there's ways of
embracing things at the same time that you're
kind of like going yeah I know what I'm doing
I know that that is that moment I'm gonna have
fun with it so I think I think you have to
I think you have to kind of find your way
toward originality and some people say there's
there's movies that don't embody some sort of
three-act structure which is absolutely true
there are films that are mini plot or anti-plot
but the thing that people have to understand
is that mini plot and anti-plot are a response
to arch plot which is three-act structure they
are responses to the classical form okay so they
take elements of three-act structure and twist
them and use them in different ways so like in a
mini plot movie you might get all the information
you might get all this information except
what you're used to getting in a normal movie
so they're messing with your expectations of
information that you get about the character or
the main character in the mini plot play or the
anti-plot play or movie may not change right but
the audience has a shift has a transformation so
they're taking these elements and turning them
around and using them in different ways but in
order to do that successfully you have to actually
understand arch plot so for those of you who are
interested in like doing really cool weird things
with structure like just learn what classical
structure is and then think about how you're
subverting it or playing with it or commenting
on it because that's where really interesting
stuff starts to happen structurally in dramatic
storytelling can you think of a movie that does
that that yeah well Tarantino does that all the
time like he plays around with these conventions
of ways that we're normally used to seeing movies
and he just messes with them he makes chapters he
flips time zones people are commenting we circle
back where are we so he does a lot of fun with
with structure because he understands what
he's playing with if people are interested
in Jim Jarmusch also creates movies that are
not the normal structure that we're used to
but these are people who are really doing like
really cool experimental stuff but they also
understand movies all kinds of movies
and that's why they're so successful
breaking the rules and subverting the conventions
so yeah so that old adage before you can break the
rules you have to know the rules that's right
that's right I believe that why is it important
for writers to start their story slowly and
take their time with introducing the characters
that's such a great that's such a great question
because we need that time to be introduced
to your characters to create that empathy that we
talked about like that's where you have the luxury
of having a little bit of time up front to
establish who they are what they want why they
want it and to allow us to kind of be introduced
to their world and really get connected to them
so that we're willing to follow them on the
journey and that takes pages I'm not saying
you should spend like 20 pages introducing your
main character you shouldn't if you're writing
a feature for sure you you pretty much do need to
kind of get to that inciting incident or that call
to adventure pretty quickly but we need but look
at wally like that little character we just like
follow him around in his little world doing his
little thing and we learned so much about him
and we basically fall in love with him and we
will follow that little robot dude anywhere
right and so but we also get introduced to the
world and the stakes in the world and that there's
nothing really living in the world and so I think
that's just a really beautiful example of visually
starting slow and letting us connect to
our character and his world and in the
queen's gambit I know we we took some time
yes and the back story wasn't always clear
why she was in the orphanage right and different
things are revealed later and it really keeps you
but why is she reacting this way oh and then
finally you see the conversation I don't want to
give away too much but yeah just little snippets
and it takes time yeah it takes time and it also
as the writer when you're writing you're starting
to write whether it's your pilot or your future
it's like your job is to create questions not give
answers your your job is to create questions like
why is she like you said why is she doing that
what's going on here so that the audience is like
we're just moving closer and closer because we
want to know why is she acting that way will
she be able to be like a chess champion will
she beat that that guy or whatever it's like
all these questions that you set up in the story
is really what holds us to the story and so in
setting up your character you don't want to just
tell us a bunch of stuff about the character maybe
we see them do something and we go that's weird
why are they doing that and we keep wondering that
until later we get the answer to that question
as as we start to fully understand kind of who
this person is and why they are the way they are
so yeah you're kind of like putting up you're
creating trails breadcrumbs and you're leaving
blank spots and one thing one thing to think
about too as a writer which I think is really
important is to create ellipses in your story
where there's gaps where maybe we if you have
a section of your script and it just feels like
here we go every then she drives
here and then she gets out then
it's like do a time cut like what's the next
scene that moves the story forward like let
us the audience actively engage with the narrative
to figure it out because the more we're doing that
the more interested we are in your story so leave
gaps ask questions and yeah take that time at the
beginning for sure why is it important for
the main character to have a transformation
oh the main character okay so let's be honest
most main characters do have transformations
in most hollywood movies right there's some growth
there are main characters who don't transform
forrest gump does he change no he just like
he just stays the same through the whole movie
the early james bond movies james bond doesn't
really change he's just getting the chicks
and bringing down the bad guy right so the thing
to remember is it's not necessarily that your
main character has to transform it's that you
need transformation in your story because that
is actually what's important so so if you
have a main character who doesn't change
and they kind of move through the story like this
what happens is they change everyone around them
like Forrest Gump changes everyone around him
but he's still Forrest Gump right James Bond
it's been interesting to watch him sort of
evolve with the Daniel Craig version because
suddenly James Bond became like this wounded
hero where he was always just the suave
martini girls blasting off into space Roger Moore
he was the one that I grew up with Roger Moore
but it's been interesting to watch his character
evolve and become more of a character that has a
tiny bit more of an emotional range in the
in the stories but yeah it transformation
in a story is a key element and whether
it comes through your main character
or your main character changing everyone else
it doesn't matter it's just that transformation
is actually the purpose of a story it's actually
the purpose of the story because the reason we
tell stories is to actually understand ourselves
better and that insight is a transformation for us
okay so however you package your transformation
in your story have at it it's up to you
but the reason we watch
stories is to be transformed
so if someone were looking to write a Forrest Gump
type scenario maybe leave it for a few scripts
down the line because that was very specific
how all that was done and there's many timelines
yeah that was a very complex script for sure
yeah it's easier to write a story where the main
character changes right because it's just clearer
or whatever but if you really have a character
who doesn't change who kind of takes us through
the story but really the point of the movie is how
this person changes the world around him or her
or them then for sure write that story it's just
it's just ha think about how why is that
person why is that person the catalyst to
change all these other people and how can they
change the world around them yeah great great
yeah I'm not sure with queen's gambit I would
say she she had a shift she did okay I mean it's
not a huge one right right it's like did
she really change but I felt like she did
because I felt like I don't know I'm not an expert
on the queen's gambit but I like I love what scott
frank did because she's she's impenetrable
in a way like she really is impenetrable
and the actress is is sort of has that face that's
impenetrable and at the same time I felt like
I got close to her I got close to her like the
mask was pierced by the end of the of this of
the show even though she didn't have this huge
transformation like a lot of main characters
do but I think she I think she did she
did she did grow and we pierced her mask
we did but she did feel like an engine driving
sort of because even the camera movement
it would follow her up yes you saw she was driving
the shots yes she brings us into the world and the
scenes and she is very sort of like mask-like
and she doesn't give a lot of emotion and the
character isn't written that way and but I did
feel that I was taken on a transformative journey
for sure and that's that's a that's a true that's
a tribute to scott frank's abilities as a writer
to be able to coordinate this character who seems
at once kind of like opaque and yet at the same
time creates this feeling of transformation
by the end of that show we're just like
I've had this journey she has taken me on
this journey with her which was really great
how much easier is it for the writer if they
know from the beginning what the character wants
million times easier it's a million times easier
if you kind of know what the character wants
but there's always a starting point you think what
they want at the beginning and you start writing
with that and then it can shift and so I think
it's the most important thing like I said earlier
when I do consultations with people it's the
singular most popular problem in the script
is what do they want how are they trying to get it
what are they doing to try to get it how does that
make them face something in themselves and how do
they grow and do they finally get this thing or do
they get it in a way that they didn't expect so I
think I think I always try to start out like what
do they want because I've learned over the years
like I need to know what that is because that's
the engine that drives their actions through the
story and when I don't know that and I start to
write I'm just kind of like just driving over here
I'm driving over here I don't know it just it ends
up being I throw out a lot of pages so I think
you can start like what is their emotional need
do they want love do they want revenge what
is it that's driving them and then what's the
specific thing they think is gonna get is gonna
satisfy that need and how do they pursue that
and you may start with that and you may shift it
as you start to write you realize oh that's not
what they want at all they want this other thing
so then you're gonna have to go back and kind
of reverse engineer what you did but it's okay
that's the process and a lot of times characters
goals shift in the movie like in get out which
is a great movie chris he wants to go and press
her family in the middle of the in the middle
of the movie his goal shifts to like I need to
get out of here they're going to hijack my body
and my brain right so so that that shifts in in
the story but but that's good that's okay but
he still has a goal throughout that drives him
and you've said before that sometimes when
you sit down to write that your character
sometimes starts to tell you what they want
in a sense yeah I just had an experience with
this barf thing that I did this thing that I just
vomited out like I'm just gonna write right right
and I was just like I kind of had the plot in my
head because again this side the left side is so
dominant in my brain and I was just like okay
this is when this happens and then suddenly
she's in the middle of the scene and like there's
a flashback where somebody's she's curled up in a
ball in the bathroom and someone's throwing movie
magazines at her from the 1940s and I was like
then I went back into the scene I'm like well
that just happened I don't know what happened
to her but something happened to her and then
I kept writing and then again when I went back
that was where all that whole backstory
is what the whole thing is really about
why she's doing what she's doing what she's gonna
have to face in the story but that was never in
my brain that that would ever happen I would that
there were that flashback was just going to pop up
in the middle of my writing but it was great
they she started talking to me she started
telling me stuff that happened to her and
I was like okay what if we can't figure out
what the character wants oh wow yeah what if
you can't figure out what the character wants
again a very common issue right some strategies
that you might do to try to figure out what
the character wants is to figure out what
they're afraid of what are they afraid of
like what are they scared of and what
do they want that's in contrast to that
does the could their want come from wanting the
opposite of that fear do what I mean if they're
afraid let's say they were had a traumatic past
or traumatic childhood could they really want
just the perfect family could you start from
fear and generate a want as the opposite of that
that's one way to kind of try to generate some
ideas about what your character could want
one thing that I often do with my clients and
my students is I have them write a monologue
and monologues in movies are we're not supposed
to write monologues it's one of the rules but
what this exercise is actually really helpful
and what I ask them to do is to sit down and
imagine their character is in a room with
someone else in the movie that they trust
another character that they trust
and that other character says
what do you want and this character
tells that other character what they want
and I ask the writers to use all their five
senses to describe this dream that they have and
just to allow that character to talk to the writer
and describe what they want with no preconceptions
and usually out of and I say write for five
minutes and don't stop so just stream of
consciousness I want this and somewhere in there
is the is a kernel of something that they can
actually grab onto and hold on to so again giving
an invitation to your character to speak to you
about what they want so if they don't know what
the character wants it doesn't necessarily mean
they need to abandon it that that character is not
really connecting with them no okay no it's just
that they don't know yet they have to listen they
aren't listening they're trying to like put things
on the character if you step into the character
and let them talk they will tell you things so
let them tell someone else in the movie what
they want what are the ways a writer can create
stakes for their character oh great question
so obviously stakes are really important for
characters because they create suspense and
tension around the goal right so if they don't
achieve what they want to achieve something
terrible will happen they will lose something
there linda seeger wrote this really great book
called how to make a good script great it's not
just for rewriting you can use it to write a
first draft but she actually has a really great
chapter on stakes and what she came up with
is a list of what is a list of stakes for any
human being and I I'm going to try to remember
off the top of my head but it's like survival
love and belonging security security uh the
aesthetic which is a sense of order control
self-actualization which is self-expression so
the loss of any one of these things on this list
is devastating for a human right survival
physical survival oh my god I'm dead right
love and belonging if we don't have love
and belonging we're basically dead safety
and security we also need that if we don't have it
it's going to be bad right so all of these stakes
one way to think about that is to look at her list
and I think it's online somewhere if people want
to check it out but but look at that list and and
think about it in relation to my character's goal
if they don't like for example if I don't
make that person love me what will I lose love
which ones on this list am I gonna lose and if
you if you watch a lot of movies and you think
about this and you think about the stakes that
the writers have set up for their main characters
usually it's everything on that list except
for one or two things they stack the stakes
for the main character so it's just not love and
belonging it's also safety and security it's also
self-actualization it's actually maybe later
in the movie something happens where now it's
survival I'm gonna die they pile on the stakes
and every good writer has to be able to articulate
what the character is gonna lose if they don't get
what they want again everything is connected to
the character and their goal so if they don't
get this thing what will be lost and the more
you can stack those stakes for your character the
more tension and suspense and kind of like we're
just gonna be like oh no they're not gonna if they
it's just gonna create in the audience this like
connection and fear that they're not gonna get
what they want which is what you want in the story
so just like the is that Maslow's hierarchy of
needs yeah so I think at the at the very bottom
of it or area I'm trying to think if I flipped it
so self-actualization I think is is the last one
yes and then survive safety and survival yeah okay
and Linda Seger created the screenwriting version
of that list nice yeah okay and so if you took
like a jenga piece if we take one of those away
then that that's gonna raise the stakes no
matter what it is yeah okay yeah interesting yeah
like I was thinking about the movie coco the Pixar
movie Coco about the little kid Miguel who has to
go to the land of the dead so he can find his
ancestor so that he can become a musician which
is what he's meant to be right and I went through
Linda Seger's list of all those stakes and he had
everything except one and it that's just good
writing he's not just gonna physically possibly
die he's gonna lose his family he's gonna lose
safety he's gonna not be who he's meant to be like
everything like this kid it's gonna it's gonna
be horrible if he doesn't achieve his goal and
so again the writer has to be able to understand
and articulate what's at stake for the character.